Nói Miet Tán tháng 5, Ngá Nghe khu chăm 5, các quan cạnh rất đều tra công an tỉnh vụ thọ trở biết đang tạm giữ hình sự đối tự hả thì Lai Hà.
Xin năm hành hình khu chăm 5 2, chú tại khu một xa phù Mỹ, phù thọc, về hình bí giết người.
Chứ đó, khoảng rà dự hôn qua, phòng cạnh rất hình sự công an tỉnh vụ thọt tiếp nhận tìm báo về việc anh với tiến đe,
Xin năm hành hình, vì vợ là hả thì Lai Hà dùng vụ phía tình công sĩnh đến tử vòng.
Ngay khi nhận được tìm báo, phòng cạnh rất hình sự đã tổ chức khám nghiệm hiện chil, tự thì.
Qua chiến đều tra sách định khoảng hung dự 2,5 mềm bệnh tháng 5, 2 bộ trồng hả cùng đi ăn liên hoàn uống dự dụ dụ dụi về nhà ở khu một, phù Mỹ,
sau đó dự 2 bộ trồng sĩ ra một tướng cạnh nhau. Hà đã sự dụ hủ khi đâm vào mạng sửa bên trái anh đây,
đã nhân bỏ trẻ ra ngoài thí hả thức dụng dụi theo chồng.
Cũng lúc này, ông quyến tiến mở vào 3 thịt thú hát, bỗ mề của dành, cân ăn như không được.
Anh đây và hả lấy nhau khoảng 5 năm nay, có quan trái năm tụi, 2 người lần công nhân, cùng chung một công.
Hình cơ quan cạnh rất đều tra công an tình của thỏ tiếp tục đều tra,
cùng của ông sửa đề sửa lý theo quy định của pháp lật.